it is interesting to see the corporate
media's response here because when
Donald Trump was President of the United
States when there was leakers within his
administration they were cheered they
were celebrated they were promoted their
story many times was just reported
without even questioning a verification
sometimes but now we have a leaker and
then the Washington Post and the New
York Times track it down with bellicat
track them down and hunt them down that
that's a big component of the story that
people have been pointing out that the
mainstream media basically acted like in
in like an intelligence operation
extension of the state yep for the state
that is when the government was like hey
who leaked this all of the newslett said
we're going to hunt this person down and
figure out who it is but when it came to
Donald Trump's leakers they were like we
must protect whistleblowers that's the
game being played today man yeah I mean
we need sweeping whistleblower
protection reform I think that that
that's a a new type of legislation that
just needs more Focus